so many young Americans feel that the
American dream is unattainable you've
got to remember these young people this
cohort of individuals men and women
never lived in a time of rising interest
rates or inflation and obviously these
are great Cycles but for 30 years rates
have been going down so affordability of
housing which is the number one issue
when you get married you want to start a
family and you're you're in your mid 20s
you look at housing and obviously
there's been a ground shift for them
because mortgages are no longer three
and a half or 4% they're more like seven
or eight so they've doubled in a matter
of months that's number one number two
they've never lived through a period
where protein or eggs or food Goods went
up 20 30% 40% since the beginning of the
pandemic hi Mr Wonderful here and I am
small business does your company qualify
for the employee retention credit find
out at Wonder trust.com educate yourself
with a live expert at Wonder trust now
because the ERC program is going to end
soon